the power is back on in most of
california this morning after the
heatwave strain on the grid forced a
rare state order for rolling outages on
friday
the broiling heat and bone dry
vegetation are fueling
three wildfires in southern california
the lake fire which has burned more than
17 000 acres in the angeles national
forest is only 12 percent contained
a forest fire that prompted evacuations
north of los angeles friday
has been contained evacuation orders
were lifted for a brush fire in the
city's foothills
about one third of the nation is in the
grip of dangerous heat warnings and
watches are in effect from the west to
the southern plains meteorologist jeff
buradelli
has more on the nation's weather jeff
good morning
hey good morning dana and good morning
everybody so this is really a sweltering
heat wave in fact one of the worst that
we've seen
over the past decade couple of reasons
big heat dome right there but look at
that area of low pressure funneling
moisture
moisture into california so this is not
going to necessarily be the driest
of heat waves and when you see the
purple there those are record-breaking
intensities of heat in the west we're
going to see about 200 record highs over
the next week or so
probably break anywhere from texas
westward especially
along the west coast high temperatures
today blazing heat about 104 degrees in
midland
look at that palm springs 119 degrees
we'll zoom in a little bit more
to that area 114 degrees in las vegas
look at
medford oregon at 111 degrees there so
just
you know limit the amount of time that
you're spending outdoors it is going to
be a scorcher
palm springs 117 tomorrow and look at
that phoenix
114 degrees yesterday they got to 117
tied for the hottest that they've ever
seen in the month of august and this
summer has been
sweltering the hottest on record in
phoenix they've seen 38 days of 110
degrees
plus and they're gonna see six more of
that six more days in a row of that
you know climate change is definitely
contributing to this heat wave in fact
the west
is warming faster than pretty much any
other place in the united states and i
want to leave you with one more thing
the tropics and the good news with this
is we have two systems on a
record-setting pace but both of them
are headed out to sea jeff those numbers
are crazy 119
in phoenix today 111 in medford oregon
wow all right jeff bernelli thank you
very much it's a dry heat but that
doesn't happen
thank you very much jeff